now you may think party conference
season is over but this week the Green
Party a gathering in Newport for their
annual get-together and the party's
co-leader Sean Barie joins us now from
there thanks very much for being on the
program this morning now the Green Party
believes there is a climate emergency
and if that is true then you're going to
have to take some pretty radical policy
policy decisions to tackle it what
exactly do you think needs to happen
well we need to change essentially every
single way that the economy works there
Caroline Lucas our conference yesterday
put forward some motion for a
sustainable economy act and that would
look at absolutely everything that we do
in the economy and switch that away from
carbon emissions from fossil fuels make
sure that we're building the sustainable
local economy that we need in the UK and
making sure for example that we deal
with the the city of London as Mayor of
London Candida I can say that we need to
engage with the with the city to make
sure that we're not using our financial
institutions to fund exploitation and
resource extraction in the global South
which also exposes people these are
really really big issues that we are
looking at in the round as the Green
Party at home for example cancelling hs2
committing that money to local transport
to making buses free across the country
all these are things that absolutely
need to change and need looking at in a
radical way in the road right through
the economy with this new act with
greens in the Treasury making those
decisions talking about radical ideas to
tackle climate change do we all need to
stop eating so much meat I think most
people recognize the impact that
particularly beef and lamb farming have
on carbon emissions and a lot of us is
looking to ways to cut down on the meat
in our diets and I think that's that's a
big thing that a lot of people are doing
and needs to be facilitated we are
seeing more products coming forwards
where you've got proteins that are that
are not meat but also your people think
doing things in work places like
meat-free Mondays those are really
really good initiatives and just cutting
shifting our agriculture away from using
our land third for me using it more for
plant-based diets and for the kind of
rewilding and reforestation that will
help with climate change as well those
are really important things that that
we've been talking about at this
conference and obviously Greens have
been talking about for 30 plus years as
well I mean how far would you go would
you consider a meat tax for example to
try and encourage this our taxation
system does need to change but I think
in terms of agriculture there the main
thing is working with farmers to see how
they can change their practices make
sure that any meat they produce is very
high welfare cut down on the overall
volume and really think about how we use
our land I think that's that's the most
important thing that we serve it's the
taxation force with the detail you are
looking after the land if the taxation
system needs to change would you
actually consider and meet tax then well
I think I mean we need to have a carbon
tax throughout the system and I think
possibly the right way to do it is not
to tax meat at the counter but also to
tax the the things that lead to the the
carbon emissions in the first place at
other points in one thing we've talked
about is having a tax on aviation fuel
it's absolutely ridiculous that aviation
fuel doesn't have a tax on it that's a
really big contributor to our carbon
emissions as well and that's something
that absolutely needs correcting at an
international levels those are things
that they absolutely need to be done now
we could be hurtling towards a general
election sooner rather than later what
discussions are the Green Party having
about potentially standing aside in
certain seats to allow other parties a
better shot at winning we're coming off
some of our best elections ever this
year we've more than doubled our number
of councilors with more than doubled our
number of em EPS in Europe and we're in
a very very strong position at the
moment and other parties are keen to
talk to us about working together and I
think it is important that all the
parties look at where we target our
resources because what we don't want to
see is a Tory
No Deal perhaps it push through by Tory
majority government and that's a real
risk we've run in the larger election
going forward so we are prepared to talk
to any party that wants to talk to us
about making fair arrangements for
fighting the general election in ways
that target our resources most
effectively
and obviously in the European elections
there are many seats so we came first or
second where we're strong challengers to
be MPs and it's very important that we
gain more MPs more green MPs like
Caroline Lucas in Parliament who can
make the case for these big changes that
we need to make on the ones in assembly
where I've been for three years we've
made big changes to Sadiq Khan's
policies we've pushed him in the right
direction
and greens are showing right around the
country and councils as well that way
you've got green voices in the room
things move in the right direction
things change people listen and people
are casting their votes with that in
mind as well so I think we're looking
forward to the general action and we are
talking to other parties about how we
can fight that most effectively in a way
to prevent the the crash out brexit that
the Conservatives would like to impose
on us
you mentioned Carolyn Lucas there of
course we know that the Green Party
holds one seat right in Pavillion are
there any other areas where you would
expect other parties to stand aside to
allow a Green Party candidate to have a
better shot well you'll understand why I
wouldn't talk about individual seats or
anything online in detail right now
because it's really important that we we
build trust with other parties as well
but certainly we are challenging you
know without any help from anybody else
for the seats in Sheffield and Bristol
and Norwich where we've done very well
in the past as well and we are the best
challengers to the Conservative Party on
the Isle of Wight as well so those seats
we can fight without anybody else's help
but I think you know other seats we are
we have you'll forgive me for not
talking about now you are of course in
the Green Party candidate for London
Maire what went through your mind when
you heard that Rory Stewart was going to
be entering the race I think what he
doesn't have is the records that the
Greens have in London we've had Green
Assembly members for 20 years making
every single Mayor of London do things
better making them listen to us and and
he needs to be making sure that he
understands London I mean I said that he
wants to walk through every borough as
if that's something special every single
mayoral candidate has to do that and
I've super mayor twice before this is
the third time I'll be standing last
time I was
third and I think potentially with the
Conservative Party votes split I've got
a very good chance of coming second in
first place votes and obviously the way
the election system works in London all
bets are off there as to who can come
first and I think Sadiq Khan needs the
strongest possible challenge he is
failing on a number of climate related
issues on clean air on housing he's not
pushing hard enough for the government
to give us more powers and and I'm a
very very good candidate to be putting
forward the case for all of those things
to be done and that's what London is
really want and what they really want
from their mayoral candidates two very
quick final thought what's your
favourite London pub my favourite lens
info I probably have to go for my local
which is the junction Tavern which is a
lot of my custom over the years okay
thank you very much Sean Barie thank you